okay let's get to a few other stories
um there's been a lot of talk from
Donald Trump about his record in
endorsing people and it'll be
interesting to see with Glenn Younkin
winning in Virginia how much credit
Donald Trump takes Trump taking a a
moment during his interview with Janine
Pirro over the weekend to say I endorsed
youngkin and I endorsed him strongly I
assure you if youngan had lost Trump
would have said well I endorsed him but
he didn't really embrace me um jungen
did win and presumably Trump's going to
take credit there Trump's record is
actually not that great on endorsements
but not only from a numbers standpoint
Trump's also endorsed some really
horrible people uh one such person
appears to be Senate candidate Sean
Parnell who now is Accused by his wife
of strangling her and beating their
children there's a report in Rolling
Stone about this which says wife of
trump-backed Senate candidate Sean
Parnell claims he strangled her
beat their children
estranged wife Lori Snell also alleged
the Republican candidate told her to go
get an abortion Lori Snell the estranged
wife of Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Sean Parnell testified during a court
hearing on Monday alleging that her
husband strangled her
um Parnell denies this also made other
claims her testimony which alleged both
verbal and physical abuse took place
during a hearing in Butler Pennsylvania
in a child custody proceeding over their
three children in their divorce case she
had previously sought temporary
protective orders against Parnell in
2017 and 2018 although both were later
expunged former president Donald Trump
endorsed Sean Parnell in September for
his run in the Republican primary
Parnell is vying for Pennsylvania's open
senate seat in 2022 in what's shaping up
to be one of the most hotly contested
Senate races next year that is a big
race
um
she said he tried to choke me out on a
couch and I literally had to bite him he
was strangling me in another incident
she claimed Parnell slapped one of the
children so hard it left visible
fingerprint-shaped welts she also
testified he was verbally abusive and
another incident she alleged he forced
her out of her vehicle and told her to
go get an abortion now that's
politically relevant because on
parnell's campaign website he States I
am pro-life will always vote to protect
The Unborn if true and these are
allegations if true it would be another
instance of hypocrisy of a gap between
stated values and how they actually live
in real life
in a statement issued by the campaign
Parnell denied the allegations and said
he would present the truth to the court
next week let me emphatically State I
have never raised a hand in anger
towards my wife or any of our three
children what happened today in court
was not Justice nor did it have any
basis in fact or truth now a lot of
people will write to me they'll say
David how you know you can't say these
things happened these are allegations
which have been refuted and that's
absolutely and completely fine I'm more
interested in the reality the undeniable
reality that these types of allegations
even when proven credible no longer
torpedo your chances at least if you're
a republican we've actually seen you
could argue to a fault over the last
decade the Al Franken incident is
arguably one of these situations where
Democrats hold their own to very
different standards than Republicans
um and there was a time when something
like this would kill your shot at
winning in times of really change you
could argue that a key moment in this
trajectory was when the Access Hollywood
tape came out with Donald Trump talking
about when you're famous they just let
you do it you just grab them by the you
know what
nothing happened nothing happened there
was a time when that could have ended a
campaign today it won't even necessarily
get Donald Trump to revoke his
endorsement of you for now Donald Trump
has not revoked his endorsement of Sean
Parnell I wouldn't expect him to for the
time being hell Sean Parnell could end
up being the Republican presidential
candidate this wouldn't even necessarily
disqualify him uh from that so it is
very much the case that the Pennsylvania
Senate race is going to be a big big
deal in um 2022 the 2022 elections in
the United States are going to be
wide-ranging and important there are
actually a number of seats uh
Pennsylvania
Ohio
um
maybe maybe Missouri
um North Carolina and Alabama where
there are retiring Republican Senators
retiring Republican Senators doesn't
mean a Democrat can win but it at least
will not be a Democrat going up against
an incumbent and those are real
opportunities and as we've talked before
about the Joe manchin problem I continue
to say the way to fix the Senate is by
flipping some red States blue it's not
by primary mansion and then having
whoever defeats Mansion if anybody lose
to a republican in the General in West
Virginia it's just it's literally not a
solution in that it actually gives
Republicans an additional seat so we're
going to keep an eye on the Sean Parnell
allegations another beauty of an
endorsement from Donald Trump these are
just allegations for the time being just
important to mention that